[Musique]
il y avait un candidat au bal au
Canada quand vous votez pour lui Je vais
certainement regarder ses références et
oui je pourrais penser qu'Eva n'est peut-être pas ce que
les gens ne sont pas ici mais il a raison de
dire la vérité et la vérité fait beaucoup de mal  des gens
que j'aime l'idée d'un homme d'affaires, je ne sais pas
si je voudrais quelqu'un qui
ressemble exactement à Donald Trump, mais quelqu'un
qui est une bonne entreprise et qui connaît le
travail économique, je pense que ce serait un
bon choix, mais aussi ce club  vous savez
tout le vinebox sonic et au niveau du moteur
rev Warren toit ou politique et c'est
Donald Trump et je suppose que je parle
récemment des intestins bien sûr je
pense qu'ils devraient faire plus attention à qui
ils laissent entrer, ils veulent que leur culture
soit notre culture et  nous ne sommes tout simplement pas comme
ça nous avons notre propre culture ils ont
leur culture cela ne nous dérange pas s'il
pleut ici par une personne décente à droite
c'est ce que je ressens alors ce que je suppose un peu
Mira Tonkin Gulf un Donald Trump udita
jeanie15 en désaccord Pujols Albert  Je
suppose que je gamin ec  onomy pris de moi Oh
voir lyst jusqu'à la visite de Donald Trump
certains baléares daniel Smith limite Ronnie
Matilda Roger dictature a Seewald
Rosa back un conservateur sur un vecteur y
lucas abduch certains voyagent un Donald Trump
visuellement elle déclare voter ce n'est pas
un lasik similaire  l'activité physique ici
aussi, l'une des choses que j'entends
beaucoup de la part des conservateurs, c'est qu'ils ont l'impression
d'avoir été fermés dans le
débat public, on a l'impression qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils essaient de soulever des problèmes légitimes,
on les appelle  un
raciste ou sexiste ou un homophobe ou
sectaire ou maintenant islamophobe et ils ont l'
impression que Donald Trump est le
candidat anti politiquement correct Daniel
Smith reste une pure joie et la question vient
qui est toujours Donald Trump nous sommes
surtout si vous le Canada si nous ne pouvons pas
avoir des discussions honnêtes sur ces
préoccupations, nous les traitons d'une manière qui
satisfait les gens, je pense que cela va
donner lieu à un candidat qui peut puiser
dans cette frustration momentos como
des parents assez étranges possèdent des koozies je serai
envoyé extrêmement bas louer une immigration appropriée
vérifier posté pues que me la Cruz
Carson para vencer le drame n'est pas
la pilule américaine traduction originale pacifique
américain le monde la conoci meezerman
STM elton john mackey normal bientôt
incident normal un  neurologique sur la vallée du charbon
Kakaako mar del monkey mustafa crochet à
ce mec l'armée du Maryland nous
lions avec succès la phonétique de la nourriture polymère
nous avons lancé la
ligne d'assistance téléphonique sur l'islamophobie afin que lorsque les gens subissent des
incidences d'islamophobie ou de
racisme anti-musulman, ils peuvent appeler
l'expression de la ligne  de préoccupation vous avez
vu une mise à jour à falmouth toute la
confiance que nous ne nous attendions certainement pas
à recevoir deux ou trois appels aujourd'hui
vous voyez la commodité misc regarder pour le
reste sont la preuve que Pocoyo augmente le prix
téléphonique passionnant espère bien le
fermer J'espère que c'est proche  celui-ci donc via
hotline hotline down